so let's let's check out this story and
I also thought was interesting because I
have fun little ideas about like fake
conspiracy theories that we were talking
about this like the origins of humans on
other planets Venus and Mars and other
silly ideas so this will be another one
of these segments but let's let's read
the story first the asteroid that hit
earth nearly thirteen thousand years ago
and ended the plate plate placed this
place that Pleistocene Pleistocene era
era like I can't pronounce names I think
I pronounce Pleistocene I've never seen
that word likely wiped out an ancient
civilization in in what is modern-day
Syria according to newly discovered
evidence Oh serious huh the research
published in scientific reports notes
that experts discovered remnants of
glass that were created during a high
impact event as well as minerals such as
chromium iron nickel and others all of
which formed in temperatures higher than
2200 degrees Celsius according to a
statement from the University of
California Santa Barbara to help with
perspective such high temperatures would
completely melt an automobile in less
than a minute said one of the study's
co-authors and UC Santa Barbara M
earnest professor of geology James
Kennedy in a statement the discovery was
made at a site known as ha boo hoo
hooray rah hooray Rock which was
abandoned roughly five thousand years
ago
known as the Pleistocene epoch the most
recent ice age is generally defined as
starting 2.6 million years ago and
ending approximately eleven thousand
seven hundred years ago the glass is
believed to have formed from the nearly
instantaneous melting of vapor
vaporization of regional biomass soils
and floodplain deposits followed by
instantaneous cooling according to the
study can it added the materials found
are extremely rare under normal
temperatures but common during impact
events a single major asteroid impact
could not have caused this widely
scattered material discovered at Abu
hooray ah and that is and that it was
more likely a fragmented comment the
rate richer said I got a pause for a
second cuz I'm gonna tell you what it
really was bump-bump I'm doing with my
hands right here aliens you know the
mean yeah
aliens we're gonna play ancient aliens
it's gonna be fun it's gonna be fun but
let's read this the largest cometary
debris clusters that are proposed
to be capable of causing thousands of
airburst within a span of minutes across
one entire hemisphere of Earth can it
explained the Younger Dryas boundary
hypothesis proposed this mechanism to
account for the widely dispersed Koval
materials across more than eight
thousand seven hundred miles of the
northern and southern hemispheres our
Abu hooray our discoveries strongly
support a major impact event from such a
fragmented comment previous studies have
focused on the Younger Dryas event a
period that saw the extinction of
species such as woolly mammoths bison
and Giants laws causing global
consequences on October 20 19
I study was published that set a brief
ice age period occurred roughly twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago and was
caused by an asteroid impact after
researchers found high levels of iridium
and platinum in white pond near Elgin SC
an enormous crater first discovered in
2015 but not officially verified until
November 2018 left a 19 mile crater in
Greenland and may have caused the
disappearance of the Clovis people a
mysterious prehistoric group that
vanished that a trace according to the
Sun you know why I find this story
really interesting why don't you tell us
do you guys remember that story I was
telling you where I don't know if you
were there remember the story I was
telling you about the the human origins
on Venus escaping yeah this is a silly
like kind of joke I thought of but this
fits into my story so perfectly go on
giant impact nuclear war a people who
mysteriously vanished
so so here's what here's the kind of
like fun story idea I had in lines with
like ancient aliens I like to think
about and this is just for fun I don't
mean this any at all in a literal sense
but I grew up Catholic okay I would to
church we would read the Bible we read
the stories and so I'd often think to
myself when I started getting older and
started becoming much less faith you
know based I guess no longer very like
theistic aliy religious and as they're
thinking about how could you explain
these stories from the from the
perspective of people with limited
understanding of technology and what
could their analog be to modern current
events and then things start to make you
can make them make sense in a scientific
context like when you hear a story about
a great flood and an arc and two of
every
of two of every animal well on the
surface it doesn't make sense but when
you apply it to the modern context of
ocean level rise due to glacial ice
melting mm-hmm a great flood could occur
an arc a ship that's you know whatever
straight forward and two of every
species as in like the DNA of two of
every species right right so so here's
the the I'm gonna tell you all the
ancient aliens fun scenario idea that
again I'm stressing that I'm not saying
is literal but it's a fun you know so
here's the the gag sort of idea humans
originated on Venus a runaway greenhouse
effect causes this sulfuric acid rain
destroys the environment and then what
would happen right now so this is kind
of the idea I was having like if we take
global warming to their natural
conclusion where they say the world is
gonna end
mmm-hmm flooding happens right so what
would humans do well like in the movies
we see them mobilize a massive ship they
do it in every movie you know about the
end of the earth like water roll well
Waterworld was different that was like
the after the collapse oh yeah but uh
like 2012 or whatever they've been the
big ships oh yeah so so let this way if
the world was about to face an imminent
disaster due to global warming like
massive flooding we probably build a big
spaceship and we probably put a bunch of
animals seeds and DNA on it it sounds
very much like an ark in a foot isn't it
would Bezos is trying to do Elon Musk is
Bates gonna do that yeah you mention
that this is a story we ran across right
before the show oh yeah right oh that's
right a giant yet trying to make an ark
see and then so check us out check us
out here's my here's my fun idea like I
think is actually be a really cool idea
for a short film mm-hmm you have a
planet with a runaway grants effect
destroying the environment and then what
would happen if right now we are facing
this catastrophe the military would
absolutely start implementing emergency
procedures that's what they're doing but
it would be a Thor Terry 100% yeah it
would be the military in control and if
you want to survive you do as you're
told and you know what I can understand
that in that context the apocalypse is
happening and you have a hierarchical
military system saying here's the ships
you get on help work otherwise we die
that's that's an understandable
circumstances and I'm not talking about
like locking people in camps like China
does I'm talking about
like American militaries are much more
liberal they're just you know
hierarchical chain of command yeah so
let's say you get the [ __ ] built it's
being led by a you know five-star
general he's no one questions him he's
in charge but now earth is gone no
government no democracy no voting and
they're in a ship heading towards Mars
and the ship stays in orbit with all
this beautiful technology up in the
heavens and the regular people who are
survived insurance salesmen you know you
got a gardener yeah you have no idea how
any of this stuff works they couldn't
they can't build a toaster they can't
both the toaster they can't engineer
anything and so they get sent down with
basic tech to start terraforming the
planet and they have no idea what's
going up there and then I look at this
story about 13,000 years ago a group of
people who vanish and something being
turned to glass due to a high impact
what was the story in the Bible where he
says if you turn around you'll be turn
into a pillar of salt Sodom and Gomorrah
is that what it is yep yep so right and
so there was the ancient aliens people
say that like I've actually watched I'm
pretty sure it's that crazy about the
Harries like aliens
he's like well I don't know if it was
actually him but they mentioned what
could turn you into a pillar of salt
from the perspective of someone who
doesn't understand technology a nuclear
bomb it would vaporize in an instant run
away from it don't turn around or you
will turn to a pillar of salt I mean you
can't really run from the bomb that's
gonna turn you if you're if you're
standing here don't look at but here's
but here's but here's the explanation
here's the hold on okay here's the
explanation the explanation is that
breaking down translations over a long
period of time and translations become
literal the Everett's you ever take like
a phrase and put it into Google
Translate and run it through ten
different language and bring it back to
English no you can see how it kind of
makes sense but doesn't make sense right
so you'll say like you know run from the
lion and then eventually it turns into
like operate a program from a giant cat
and you're like what does that mean
because ron has so many different
different but you know definition no
longer makes any sense right so the
original idea and the fun idea is that
you have this evacuation from one planet
with almost Venus right almost no
technology surviving they they come to
earth and starts eating it with the life
from the other planet mm-hmm and then
it's you know over that's why you have
like these explosive periods of life
disappear
and then they bring down a bunch of
regular people who have no idea how any
of this technology works how nuclear
energy works no they have no idea how
weapons working it like a regular FET
you know might take a fat dude on his on
his you know in his lounge chair
watching football dropped my new planet
and see what he can do yeah and then you
end up with people trying to document
what's happening to passed on the
information in two or three generations
their kids are gonna have no idea like
the next kids that are born on that new
planet right will never even know
electric lights exist cellphones existed
video games existed and they'll have an
idea of something like magic exactly
touch this thing and light happen yep
and their parents will tell them that
there were smart men who could create
devices that would give you access to
all of the information of the universe
and they were like wow and then to them
in their mind it's magic yeah and so
they write it down in the book magic a
thousands of years go by and it's magic
yeah yeah so so who are these people who
disappeared the people who were working
on the ship who are coming down as the
first terraforming colonists mm-hmm they
there's a nuclear bomb dropped there's a
war and a conflict happening so one of
the so I started thinking about these
ideas and thought it'd be a really cool
short film idea and it would but it
would borrow from some like mythologies
and and religions to try and turn it
into a sci-fi and I imagined it like you
have a militaristic ship the Ark
carrying all the the remnants of the of
the technology of you know of Earth as
the planet was destroyed and then after
you know 20 or 30 years you get one of
the commanders saying it's time to
implement a democratic government on the
new colonies and he says no because in
his mind he views it as I must be obeyed
otherwise everything will fall apart and
everyone will lose their lives and then
humanity is wiped out but the other
people are saying no it's time we can't
live this way anymore and we need to
establish legitimate democratic forms of
government and then a war breaks out and
then he nukes the people who you know
who opposed him and then takes his
people out and they're gone so it's just
I don't know fun ideas like exploring
they're parked on the dark side of the
moon no they're gone 13,000 years ago
yeah I don't know how long a ship could
last drifting off into space like there
was a movie I saw where they're on a
cruise from Earth to
I think Mars okay and then they get an
unexpected bombardment of asteroids oh
so they do an emergency maneuver but it
is a massive massive vehicle dodging it
burns up too much fuel and they can't
recover and they're on a trajectory
that's just drifting you know at a high
rate of speed
what movie was that but they get there
like hopefully you know earth finds out
and launches emergency fuel towards them
so they could turn around but never
happens and so they end up just drifting
for millions of years and then finally
after like a million years there's
nothing on the ship anymore but it like
comes to an earth-like planet so and
then stops yeah but now they're doing
like there's like a comedy show like
that I think on on HBO it was kind of
weird as I just watched this movie on
Hulu about the ship drifting in you know
for decades but now it's like from the
makers of veep I guess there's a it's a
show you know it's a new show and
they're like on a big cruise in space
and it veers off course another trapped
on it supposed to be a comedy mm-hm
anyway you know I think the ideas of
ancient aliens are really funny but it's
just fun stuff to talk about whether or
not anything is actually real the answer
is probably not but people love ancient
aliens yes they do but you know what I
love about ancient aliens no I don't
they open by saying we do not condone
any of the ideas but we are presenting
the evidence evidence
you put a janitor on TV and call them an
alien expert that's not evidence yeah
good point
yeah thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8:00 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you